[Musik]
was war das denn ich wollte gucken ob
ich aus dem Bild trage mit rein und
damit herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einem neuen Video auf meinem Youtube
Kanal meine Damen und
ich spielen heute ein Spiel namens
fantastics der
Schaukel quasi so die ganze Zeit rum und
unser einziges Ziel ist es irgendwann
auf dem Knopf zu drücken dass er sich
loslässt einen Salto macht und im besten
Falle hier auf der 100 landet der 100
kriegt man
Punkt
wenn man den in der Mitte landet kriegt
man 100 Punkte bei Rot kriegt man 25 und
bei Geld kriegt man 50
das ist so ein dummes Spiel
Digger was ist das ich komme nicht
weiter nach vorne
ich habe
machen soll doch los
[Musik]
heftige null Punkte leiser also super
Video ich merke
ausgedrückt haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du hast das ja komplett falsch aufgebaut
nein das war richtig so ach guck mal
jetzt kann man das ja auch drunter
Klemmen einmal mit Profis
aber so funktioniert also man muss die
ganze Zeit sich einmal im Kreis und da
muss man drücken und wenn man dann drauf
landet dann hat man gewonnen
du musst immer gedrückt halten wenn er
so hier dann wieder ist wenn man halt
wirklich Schaukeln würde
[Musik]
und dann kriege ich auch nicht hin oder
wie
du brauchst Geduld wenn ein Raubtier
Hunger bekommt muss es auf die Jagd
gehen
dass wir Leute
so ein dreck Spieler du musst halt immer
wenn er hier hinten ist gedrückt halten
was ist daran nicht zu verstehen
[Musik]
100 Punkte 150 ich bin dran
also das ist vielleicht wirklich das
stimmt
drauf hier drin
trotzdem gut jetzt wollen wir Bielefeld
nach dieses Mikrofon geht 200 Meter weit
ich kann nach unten gehen ich rede jetzt
irgendwas und du redest auch was wir
versuchen so Unterhaltung miteinander zu
machen ohne dass wir uns hören okay kann
ich dabei ein Einkaufswagen nein schade
ist schon weg ganz leise reden
[Musik]
geiles Video ich hoffe viel Spaß mit äh
Moneyboy und seinem Kollegen